June 20th 2014
Texas meteorologists spot a strange
pulsing object moving across their radar
screens
and the object isn't just moving it's
getting bigger within about an hour you
go from nothing to this huge fanned out
look on your radar
the chilling image is captured in the
skies above San Antonio Texas it looks
like a brain MRI not a weather pattern
Paul Yura from the National Weather
Service office near San Antonio is on
the case we started seeing these plumes
right after sunset there's gotta be
something going on out there scientists
consider that the source of the circular
mass might lie directly beneath it at
ground level for most weather people
you're going to take a look at the
spatial area what is around that land
they discover that the anomalies point
of origin appears to be a weird hold in
the earth
if you line up this radar image with a
map it turns out it's really close to a
cave
we all know it lives in caves the
occupants of the cave are historically
one of nature's most feared and
misunderstood creatures Bracken cave is
the home to the largest colony of bats
in the world there are 20 million
Mexican free-tailed bats living in the
cave now these bats migrate into Central
Texas in March and here are all summer
long to have and razor young so that's
really why this place is so special
when dusk falls the ravenous bats swarm
out in search of their prey
when you see 20 million bats emerging
from a cave it's like a scene from a
Batman movie the truth behind the
strange anomaly
is a wonder of the natural world so
whether radar is picking up these very
small bats what looks like a rain cloud
is actually a cloud of bats
[Music]
you